constructive proof
this thing up
so thank you to the organizers for
inviting me to speak here thank you for
coming I'm gonna talk about proofs of
pseudo randomness and the fact that many
of those proofs are so constructive that
the proofs themselves can be used as
algorithms my microphone is on but it's
for the recording
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
let me start again good morning I'm
going to talk about usefulness of
constructive proofs of pseudo randomness
because proof of pseudo randomness are
often so constructive that they can be
used themselves as algorithms and
sometimes these unintended uses of
proofs of pseudo randomness lead to
spectacular results in this talk I'll
talk about applications of this
constructivist II to learning algorithms
and most of this work is joint with
Russell Marko car Messina and Anthony
Nicola Coulomb so we're bunch of pseudo
random objects one can talk about
pseudo-random generators expander graphs
extractor aircraft and codes and boolean
functions that require a large circuit
complexity in this talk I'll be focusing
on the first in the last pseudo-random
generators and Hart boolean functions
and my favorite surround generator is
the Nissan Victor Shin generator and
this is a construction which takes a
function boolean function which has some
number of inputs and outputs one bit and
constructs a new function with somewhat
more input bits and with many more
output debts like polynomial in n square
input bits here and up to exponentially
many output bits and if you look inside
this construction it's nothing but
application of this single function many
times so each bit of the output of this
thing is just an application of a
function f to some subset of the bits in
the input string to the generator which
is called the seed and to pack those
subsets so that you have lots of them
and ideally don't want them to overlap
too mad too much you need to use some
construction but it's not very difficult
it's a beautiful construction and you
can achieve this packing with very small
overlap between any two sets so before I
talk about the properties of the
generator I need to define the notion of
pseudo randomness for this for
generators in general and here we have a
class of tasks boolean functions that
we're trying to fool and we have two
settings in one setting our task is
given completely uniform random strain
and another setting our test is given a
uniform random string which was passed
through the generator and stretched out
and the task of our generator is to make
sure that the test does not notice the
difference so the probability of
accepting in both situations is up to
plus minus Epsilon the same
and if this happens then the generator
is called epsilon pseudo-random
so the main result of nice and
aggressions paper is to show that you
can use hard functions to construct
should random generators so basically
they say that if you have a function
which has large enough complexity or
hard to predict by circuits of
appropriate size then you use this
function in the construction of the
generator that outlines and you get
something which is pseudo-random and you
can read the parameters they're not very
important for the stock it will be
mostly non-technical ideas rather the
proofs ok
so this object the nice and regression
generator happens to have tons of uses
some of them are listed here
the most obvious one in stood
randomization and that was the original
use from papers - and wiedersehen and
then bye-bye four minutes and bickerson
a class the victor Sun and so on and so
on
which is basically a conditional do
analyzation result saying that if you
have heart functions and people believe
that they exist and can be explicitly
computed then you can do randomized
randomized algorithms efficiently and
the quality of your randomization
depends on the quality of the circuit
complexity that you start with somewhat
unexpectedly the same construction can
be used to build extractors which are
object in the computational and in
information theoretic setting rather
computational complexity setting and
that was a beautiful observation of okay
Travis on these objects can also be used
in proof complexity unbounded arithmetic
where people care about lower bounds on
proving certain tautologies and they can
construct candidate heart autologous by
using nice and vectors and generators
and this is this been a work by Alec
Novick Spencer song raspberry Gershon
cried chakras were of pick and so on
this objects also were able to sneak in
into circuit lower bound
for example the truth that next was not
in HD c0 Byron Williams also has as one
of the components Venus on weakness and
generator in it Sony some distance
generators are like donuts there's
nothing that can do so before I talk
about more applications of this
wonderful objects let me define some
things that I will be talking about and
these are classes of circuits a constant
depth circuits called AC 0 and AC 0 mod
p and these are layered graphs or
layered graphs where the notes are
logical connectives logical gates like
and or and not the depth of those graphs
are constant and you have one output and
a bunch of inputs at the bottom and if
you allow say parity gates or a more
generally multi gates then you obtain
what is called AC 0 mod p circuits so
there's a very simple very kind of
parallelizable algorithms and the
success of circuit complexity main
success circuit actually was to prove
lower bounds against such models of
computation even though in general we
have very basically no good lower bounds
for the general unrestricted model of
circuit complexity
so our first application is to get a
learning algorithm for the class of AC 0
mod p circuits so we showed that there
is a randomized algorithm which is
somewhat efficient the transient
quasi-polynomial time which is like an
to the poly log an ideally would like
polynomial time of course but we cannot
write get that it has oracle access to
the function f that is trying to learn
and it's been promised that the function
f has a small AC 0 mod p circuit
computing it ok
so you know that the function is easy
you have oracle access to this function
and you try to build a hypothesis which
would be a circuit which hopefully
agrees with the function on many places
ok so you're trying to operate circuit c
such that it agrees with the function f
you're trying to learn on almost all
places of the boolean cube so we managed
to get this kind of algorithm and I'll
say a few words how will also get an
extension of this algorithm to the so
called agnostic settings let me explain
what it means in the picture so usually
when you talk about learning and you're
trying to learn some function f you
assume that your function f is in a
class of simple functions that you're
trying to learn in agnostic setting you
don't have this promise that your
function f is in there but you know that
it's close ok so there is somebody in
there function G such that the distance
between F and G is relatively small and
then using your knowledge of this class
AC 0 mod p in our case and in particular
you can learn anything in there you try
to leverage that to learn something
which is close to that class as well
and the goal is to learn something which
is as close as possible relative to the
distance between the function f and the
best the closest function in the class
so if the distance between F and G is
something like beta where the distance
measured just under uniform distribution
in this case then you try to learn
something which has fraction of errors
that most beta plus Epsilon for some
negligible Epsilon
and your ideally try to make this D to
be 1 but in our case we'll only be able
to achieve D some factor it's a function
on some input size a good polar if
function of the input size yes there is
no guarantee on the complexity of the
circuit except that it will be small
because their learning algorithm runs
impossible enough time so the circuit
will be at most quite a polynomial but
it won't be of type like AC zero ohm of
P or anything like that little bit
general boolean circuit Oracle it says
you don't live from uniform examples
yeah that's right that's right yes so so
here is a statement so again we have
Oracle access to the function f we're
trying to learn and we have some promise
that the function f is close to somebody
in the class say C 0 mod p and the
distance is like data and we try to
learn a circuit no restrictions on the
circuit which agrees with the function
almost everywhere where the fraction of
errors will be like beta times Palo log
n ok so it only makes sense if you start
with beta like less than 1 over poly log
gamma or smaller you start with
something which is relatively close to
the class if you can look if you want to
learn it
so how it is property testing version of
this problem like do you have a function
f which is a close so far and we need to
find out which is it much easier so
we'll get to that it's and I'm not sure
it's it's known how to do that for H 0
mod p but something like this is
actually the crucial part of the
learning algorithm as you will see so
let me just mention that previously it
was known how to learn a simpler
function that what I mentioned the so
called AC 0 function so no more PJs just
ant or the knots and this is from a
beautiful work of linear man surah nisa
and from around 89 for the learning
setting again they also get quite a
polynomial runtime and no restrictions
on the circuits that they learn and also
in the work by currents Shakir Shelly
thank you
and then Kauai clients Mansoor and share
video thank you
they got agnostic version of the same
algorithm where you just get random
examples X f of X under uniform
distribution I hit a jackpot
and the analysis uses four-year
concentration of functions computable in
AC zero which is the same property that
was used to prove circuit lower bounds
against this class of 80 zero functions
so it's kind of interesting that already
here you see that some property that was
useful to understand the limitations and
the power of AC 0 is also useful to
prove to get learning algorithms for the
same class of functions so our approach
well we cannot use for a concentration
because if you allow parity gates in
your circuit you don't have any free
concentration free concentration
basically says that if you look at your
boolean function in the Fourier domain
then most of the mass for your mass will
be on lower degree coefficients okay in
particular parity which has degree n
will not have much mass of course if you
allow AC 0 parity circuits you'll have
parity gates then parity will have huge
masses computable in a class ok so you
cannot expect any there is no real
concentration they can expect cannot use
the same methods so we'll be using
doughnuts instead and W generator so
what is in W PRG as I mentioned the
algorithm can be viewed as follows you
take a heart function f you construct a
pseudo-random generator we construct
something which you hope will be just
around generator by taking F as input
and building this function G of F G sub
F and then you use this generator G sub
F to fool any circuit G that is given to
you to analyze this algorithm you need
to argue that it works so if you have
some circuit D some test D which is not
fooled
then you need to show that your function
f was not that hard after all
so that would be stuff that would be
sufficient to argue that the algorithm
works it turns out that when you
actually have to prove such as tential
results you can't but show something
much more constructive and in particular
as was observed by in Ferguson
regression you argued this connection by
a randomized algorithm which takes an
Oracle access to the function f and
builds a circuit for F given this
distinguisher test D which was not
fooled so not only do you show that a
small circuit for F exists
you actually have an algorithm that
finds it and this algorithm that finds a
circuit needs
Oracle access to the function f and
that's the Oracle access that will
inherit in our learning outward so what
do you see in this picture
is it two images
what do you see in this picture and you
see learning algorithm the thing on the
right analysis of the PRG construction
lecture learning algorithm you start
with something which is not fooled by G
sub sub F and you build a circuit which
computes F so you learn a circuit for F
you have a learning algorithm there's
one small thing you need to get this
distinguisher D from somewhere but
module bad you have a learning algorithm
so this is how and double your
generators give you learning algorithms
so now we have to work with this
annoying part of getting a distinguisher
somewhere for our generator to complete
the picture so that we have actually
learning algorithm so if you look at the
construction of the generator that I
showed to you before it has a nice
property one of the properties is like
so-called locality what do I mean by
that if you start with the function f
which is not hard but actually somewhat
easy so suppose you know that the
function f that you used to build a
generator is actually a circuit
complexity s think of as like polynomial
in n then you can show that if you plug
this function FN and you take any seeds
e to the generator you look at its
output and you think of this output as a
truth table of a boolean function and
you measure the complexity of the truth
table of this boolean function then it
will be polynomial e related to the
complexity of the function f you start
with in other words each bit here in the
output is computed basically as an
application of F to some subset of the
seed so whatever the complexity F you
start with you inherit that complexity
in the complexity of computing the
output of this generator so we think of
the generators that kind of function
generator now so the output is treated
as a truth table of a bull and fun
and this actually observation is pretty
old it was absorbed by raspberr of at
least in 2002 in the context of proof
complexity I mentioned before that they
try to build heart tautologies candidate
autologous for proof systems like leg
and extend and Fraga and one of the main
uses of the generator in that context is
to build sets autologous basically you
need to show that something is not in
the image of the generator that would be
like a heart apology supposedly yes
yes yes so it's kind of hidden under
this polynomial in s actually they
actual complexity will be like s plus
polynomial in n where polynomial in n is
the complexity of building the design so
designs can actually be computed very
efficiently I mentioned before you're
doing some field arithmetic and it can
be very locally they efficiently compute
it so you have small overhead like
polynomial in n over hat the basic
complexity is s any other questions
so to recap together learning algorithm
it suffice us to break the generator
based on the function that you're trying
to learn to break the generator
it's the physis to distinguish easy
boolean functions from random because
what that's what we just have we need
the distinguisher to plug in into our
approach to build a learning algorithm
great
so the distinguisher is a procedure that
will take some function to table the
function G versus a truth table of
random function and it has to tell that
function G is easy not random and
function G can have arbitrary
complexities that we decide on or we try
to get the distinguisher that works
really really hard and is able to
distinguish functions which are almost
maximal circuit complexity so to the end
we black maximum to the N over 10 is
close to that so ideally we want our
generate our distinguisher to to tell
these functions from random if it's able
to do so efficiently in polynomial time
in the size of the truth table we would
get a polynomial running time for a
learning algorithm the what what we get
is distinguisher that cannot quite
achieve this but it can distinguish
function which are weakly exponential in
circuit size and that translates you
know it's not that I refined and so the
running time of the learning algorithm
becomes worse it's quite a polynomial
and if you have something very weak but
still non-trivial like you can tell
polynomial size circuit complexity from
random then you get some exponential
running time for your learning
what is the advantage okay
you mean the summation probability
constant like a half to make sure it
gets a picture sir you need some
thickness and you kind of start with a
heart function and get them sitting
there it will actually make true for
this small circuit but is that others
distinguished or something decently
right that's right yes that's right so
that's what Russell calls play to lose
strategy you start with something which
you know that the generator will be
broken with so your function f is
actually easy and then you don't use the
construction so before as you are saying
so before we actually build a generator
and then in your half you did the
analysis now it's going to be the
opposite in you actually will be running
the analysis as the learning algorithm
and in your head you'll be doing the
construction to get the properties that
you need for your learning algorithm to
work so you kind of switch the
perspectives totally other side of the
picture
so how do you distinguish easy functions
from random and again it's amazing that
if you try to procure get lower bound
most of the time you'll end up with a
constructive proof it can be formalized
using the framework of bounded
arithmetic which I won't talk about
basically a raspberr of again as well
show that almost all existing circuit
lower bound proofs can be formalized in
the sort of polynomial time reasoning
system unbounded arithmetic called s12
this is the invented by Sen bass in his
PhD thesis basically I just want to
corresponds to the polynomial time
concepts that you can deal with so if
you prove something you need to argue
the existence of some objects if you
constructive then this object that you
can strut and that the object that you
argue about actually is polynomial time
computable okay so constructive proof
basically force you to talk about things
which don't just exist but can be
efficiently computed and s12 is a bonded
organic system which has this
constructive ative property built-in so
whatever you reason about this polymer
melt and computable and he also showed
us we're also show that every such
circuit lower bound proof or an explicit
function if you can formalize it in this
system then immediately because of the
constructive nature of your proof
you get the distinguisher between easy
and random functions magically
so to prove that F is not a certain in
some circuit size s one way would be to
exhibit the property that kind of
distinguishes the two cases or easy
functions are in the property and all
and your function that you're trying to
prove hard is not in the property so
that's what you would like to do maybe
and a natural such property which you
get by doing this in the constructive
way by doing this proof in the
constructive way gives you extra stuff
so you still get that all the easy
functions are in the property but you
also get that not everything is in a
property that your property rejects at
least half of all the functions so
that's the distinction probability 1/2
that I mentioned before that is where it
comes from and the property is actually
efficiently testable so given a truth
table in time polynomial in the truth
table you can test whether you satisfy
property P or not let me just flash this
amazing natural property for a c0 ma to
do to rosboroughs
so basically take a boolean function f
and you try to figure out if it's easy
or hard the way gonna you want to work
figure it out you take a function and
build a big matrix of roughly 2 then buy
to the N size and the Ender's of the
matrix will be labeled by some subsets
of appropriate sizes I and J and for
each entry I J you basically take the
page of the function on some subset of
inputs where the subset of inputs as all
those X's which are zeroed out in the
positions I Union J so this looks very
strange
there is no intuition why it works and I
don't have time to talk about all this
intuition
yeah can you summarize
so it's like you cannot represent it as
a ratio actually it's a bit simpler than
that you can argue that any low degree
polynomial or appropriate parameters
will make the matrix 0 and if you're
close to this polynomial then how close
you are will make the rank of the matrix
to be about that so it's actually it's
maybe even simpler than what yourself
but anyway so it's possible to say
something about this thing but I don't
have much time anyways yeah and what's
the national property so you build this
matrix and then what do do you compute
the rank and you accept if the rank as
well so you can do that efficiently in
polynomial time because you can build a
matrix efficiently can compute the rank
efficiently and be done and so given
this to learn AC 0 more to functions you
just use your natural property that is
flashed as a distinguisher plug it in
and to this learning algorithm from you
stand victors and analysis and just do
this analysis part of the picture to
learn an circuit approximating F and in
your head you have the construction of
the simulation generator for the
analysis part one thing is that
approximating F is not that great
because you only get like a weak learner
1/2 plus epsilon correctness and you can
make it better by basically start with a
function which is encoding of your
function if you're trying to learn again
this is something that you do in your
head you imagine you have a few imagine
constructing a new function G which
basically the XOR of F and a bunch of
independent inputs like formula many and
then you try to be clear learn G rather
than F and once you learn G then by
constructive proof of this error
correcting code you get the small
circuit for F which is much better than
the weak learner you got for G so again
constructive proofs I use
succession play a very small input so
you can that's right that's right yes so
you have F and then you imagine running
the generator construction on this F and
you you free to choose the stretch of
this generator and in fact it's
something that I didn't have time to
mention based on the quality of your
circuit lower bounds on your
distinguisher abilities in our case it
will be like weakly exponential the
stretch you can for it will be like
quasi-polynomial and ideally you would
like to have stretch polynomial so it's
something counterintuitive again in the
randomization setting you want the
stretch to be as huge as possible
because you want to generate many random
bits but we're not doing randomized
ation we're doing the analysis the
learning part and the kind of parameters
are very different there so for the
learning part you want the stretch to be
very small because that affects the
running time of your learning algorithm
but to make it stay small you need to
start with something which can deal with
exponential circuit complexity and tell
it apart from random functions
it's related I just wanted to make sure
when maybe it's questionable smullin
because it is some kind of exponential
so you think the truth table is 2 to the
N + 1 - the same thing but then you
learning on size n this is because I
guess as that could serve me some big
gifts and grandmas is like very quick
subset so so the the learning algorithm
will depend on the output size of the
generator
onii-sama condition generator and
remember the generator just samples F in
some positions and builds this string
and the stretch can be exponential which
basically means that you encode the
truth table of F as part of the output
or it can be much much less so you kind
of sample F a little bit and we'll be
able to choose the stretch to be very
small so the only sample F a little bit
but the complexity of this thing will be
an exponential because you know this
small stretch but F is still polynomial
but stretches like polynomials we can
work out the parameters and see that you
have a based on distinguisher to handle
that so in our case we only a weak
exponential distinguished shirt so we
can handle quasi-polynomial stretch and
that's where quasi polynomial running
time is coming from
one hopefully clarifying remark so we're
learning the function app on inputs of a
big size and so we can't look at on
smaller inputs and hope that it's easier
we're so but so the complexity of
evaluating app stays the same regardless
of the stretch of the generator what can
change though is if we make the
generator output fewer bits then we're
viewing it implicitly as a function the
log of our remaining bits we we output
so that means the relative certainty
complexity of computing that function
since the dominating factor is computing
app on an input like that stays the same
and sort of independent of L if we make
L small then it has almost exponential
complexity if we make L larger than we
can make the complexity weaker but then
the algorithm takes longer
so technically learning serum or to you
basically do the same thing except that
you need stronger properties from your
distinguisher your distinguisher
shouldn't tell just easy functions from
random but functions which are close to
being easy from random and you need to
modify and W generate a little bit so
that you ensure that the output truth
tables of the generator remain close to
the class of easy functions before we
said that the function f is easy as I
was just saying then the output will
also be easy and the circuit complexity
will be appropriately changed depending
on the scratch now we start with
function f which is closed and the
output should stay closed and now put
the generator some kind of sampling
procedure so you need to make sure that
your sample in a good way to ensure that
you stay close and this is possible to
do by by adding some kind of Paris
independent component to the inside of a
custom generator I want to have time to
talk about that since I'm out of time
but the bottom line is that you can use
existing natural properties and look at
them and see that they can actually
stronger than what you thought they are
aware and you can modify the n-double
generator a bit to get something which
keeps the properties you would like to
keep
so summary you have constructive
analysis of NW generator we have
constructing proofs of circuit lower
bounds well I get learning algorithms
out we don't have natural properties
useful against ACC 0 these are general
mods or mod gates not mod prime but mod
6 and so on that would be nice to get
that if you have this then we
immediately get a learning algorithm for
this bigger class ACC 0 we would like to
have learning algorithm without
membership queries as passed if possible
like to match our man may not be
possible freshers your omatsu because of
the noisy parity and better learning for
x20 multiple would be great you know end
up here
thank you very much for a great first
talk in this workshop unfortunate we
don't have time for questions that there
is a long break after the next